i will never apologize for standing up
for an lgdp l gt lbg
lgbtq2 plus uh kids rights
to not have to undergo conversion
therapy quick someone help him by
releasing more blackface photos
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
happy wednesday so politico just
published quite the bombshell turns out
the emails from hunter biden's laptop
were authenticated
yeah imagine that authenticating things
we already knew to be true
so what are you going to tell us next
hunter likes blow and hookers
who doesn't though
well done fellas everybody in the media
take the year off uh too late you
already had yeah this news comes from a
new book but it's not new to any of us
thanks to the reporting of the new york
post and it was only because the rest of
the media wanted joe biden to win that
it was buried faster than your kids
guinea pig you accidentally stepped on
because you were drunk
but just for old times sake let's report
the so-called news a person who had
independent access to hunterbyn's emails
confirms two of the emails the post
published including one about a
potential deal with china with the line
10 held by h for the big guy that is joe
biden
i'm guessing that 10 though had more
zeros following it than joyride's
twitter account
now we already knew this because we
didn't ignore hundreds of former
business partner toady bobilinski
love that name
uh he confirmed them up forever ago the
book also confirms that emails released
by the swedish government also match
emails from the laptop i know who knew
sweden had a government
anyway but it's it's that china email
that matters it reveals the bidens were
in cahoots to make a buttload of money
with an enemy that fact would have
doomed joe's election chances if it was
treated like the deadly grenade that it
was but thanks to the press and big tech
it didn't they're more rotten than a
month old bag salad
so just for old times sake let's look
back at how the compliant media treated
the story when it first came out first
cnn check out these graphics first how
the newest anti-biden narrative was
and u.s authorities investigating if
recently published emails are tied to
russian disinformation efforts in
targeting biden
so reliable sources my ass
now i'd say stelter should eat some crow
but he might go into toxic shock because
it's a protein
[Laughter]
his only reliable source is a bucket of
raw cookie dough
and remember npr
why haven't you seen any stories from
npr about the new york post hunter biden
story well we don't want to waste our
time on stories that are not really
stories yeah right npr you do that
ignore that story and focus instead on a
legally blind transgendered pony who
makes a living doing porn
pretty good stuff by the way
here's here's msnbc why does rudy
giuliani have access to peddle this
disinformation repeatedly
this is not censorship facebook is under
no obligation to allow a disputed report
that appears to contain disinformation
enjoy read tweets good for joe biden no
need to dignify a russian hatchet job
we're not doing emails again america
come on joy you get any dumber we're
gonna start calling you don lemon
and remember remember that letter signed
by 50 former intel officers right huh
hunter biden's story is russian disinfo
dozens of former intel officials say
well either they were dupes or they were
traitors that letter came together
faster than a new bong at cat's house
yet all the hacks swallowed that bs like
it was beluga caviar look at all these
jackasses david frum max boot david corn
ben rhodes tommy vieder remember evan
mcmullen he doesn't
the list the list of dolts goes on and
on thanks to drew holden who compiled
them seriously that must be a guinness
book world record for
stack that high
and now it's so cute to see these dopes
who painted trump as a russian spy while
bearing biden's connection to china then
get mad at the dope they elected yet the
same press now cries because the guy
they carry to the white house now won't
answer their questions
i think would it be okay if we just have
a couple of
questions just uh just just a couple of
questions
he
asked a question
hope the microphone got it
i know
british reporters get questions
wow he's less eager to attend a press
conference than brian laundry's parents
but the irony is as rich as a burisma
shareholder afghanistan the drone strike
inflation covid division polarization
crime and the haitians who prove living
under bridges isn't just for americans
anymore
just eight short months biden turned
america from us first to dead last
it's like my favorite blow of doll
gladys
joe's presidency has quickly deflated
and like gladys he doesn't answer
questions either
i prefer it that way but remember he
didn't really want to run he knew he was
as done as burnt ribeye he just wanted
to go back to delaware and wander into
neighbors yards without his pants on
just like the good old days
so it's all in the press and they still
love to bury things take the border for
months horrifying video relayed the hell
that was going on but they ran from that
footage like it was an incoming zoom
call from jeffrey toobin
but the media only cared when they found
that one image they could use to
demonize border control but now surprise
surprise the so-called whipping has been
downgraded to wielding then whirling and
now it's just twirling
what's next wooing they were wooing them
turns out the only things getting
whipped at the border are joe's and
kamala's asses
the washington post now admits the
border patrol did not appear to strike
anyone yeah but you can't unring that
bell the idiots who read their garbage
digested that crap hole and will
continue to use it every time they argue
with the sane person but that paper is
now mostly fake stories and corrections
i would line my bird cage with it but
then i'd end up with a parrot who will
hate america praise china
and demand a non-cisgender pronoun
and no joy they weren't whips they were
reigns
i was not aware that whips
um which come from the slave era slavery
era were part of the package that we
issue to any sort of law enforcement or
government sanctioned personnel were you
aware that that was being issued to
people people had that kind of equipment
on them that they could use on humans
she has to be a plant
you think you'd think she'd know a
little little about being an equestrian
for all the
she produces
but now
i'm just happy i was able to say
equestrian
i practice in the mirror
with a writing crop but anyway but now
as the whip story evaporates under the
glare of common sense so goes their
attention to the border problem it shall
be buried like the laptop unless of
course they can find one more image that
will impugn americans if only there was
some of that on hunter's laptop then
they would report out of it
welcome tonight's yes
when he takes his shots at the left he
hits from a three-point range the reuben
report host dave rubin
yeah
she's so southern she moisturizes with
bricks fox business network anchor jagen
mcdowell
he was born in saudi arabia which is why
we call him our little prince
the guy benson show host and fox
contributor guy benson
and
they play her voice to make gitmo
prisoners talk fox news contributor
welcome back to the show dave last time
you were on was the first show am i
correct in that that is correct greg i
have so much to say about that opener
but first off gladys your inflatable
girlfriend we went out to dinner she did
not shut up the entire time
i i am shocked that was not gladys that
was glenn
yes he's been having hormone treatments
hence the weight gain can i just say
before we do anything else for that iq
was on the first show which was in april
right and i said on the first show that
you would be number one in late night by
the end of the year
you did it in four months yes four
months
and it's unclear to me whether it's
because you're so charming and handsome
and witty or whether the other guys are
just so absolutely horrible i'm trying
to figure it out
yeah i think i am i think i i my
competition is kind of sad and pathetic
but i'm not going to let that stop me
from reveling in my success yes i'm
still a winner dave no you're going out
with lattice tonight i'm a big winner
gladys is dead dead to me now i can have
any blow up doll i want
where are we in this segment you have a
thought
well look on the stuff that you were
just talking about you know the the idea
that we couldn't talk about the laptop
and now we can talk about the laptop
it's like everybody's a conspiracy
theorist until you're proven right right
you're not going to believe this i've
got one for you what i think there's a
chance
that uh kovid came from a lab yes in
wuhan
dagan welcome to the show you look
fantastic i can say that
yes you can actually
the fact that all this stuff is true
matter it really it's not going to
reverse anything to dave's point it
really doesn't matter that they're
talking about it now
i think it does and by the way thank you
for this blow up of hunter biden in
front of me i'm like lot's wife i gotta
you know i should look away or i'll turn
into a pillar of salt or cocaine
um if you do turn into a pillar of
cocaine no offense if we dive on
you please
please deliver it to the police and yes
immediately
um
i think this was going to backfire on
the biden administration because there
are serious reporters who are upset and
rather than covering you know paul paul
biden who acts like your grandpappy
who's taking his hearing aids out that's
what he looked like yeah he's sitting
there with the hearing aids out kind of
with a glazed look on his face like
looking around can't hear you can you
hear you so reporters are going to want
to be on the hunter biden beat and dig
up compromising dirt on biden and
familia the whole enterprise think about
it you get to travel the globe ukraine
mexico china
the left coast and you get to go to all
the places that are privileged dumb ass
crackers
you get to interview hookers
jiggle joint strip club art gallery
bougie hotels rehoboth
chateau marmar yeah exactly you don't
pronounce the tea i heard
tomorrow
no rockstar was kicked out of there
people died there he got banned
i almost love him for that
guy here's a question for you because
you're a political mind should we should
the republicans i'm not a republican
should the republicans start impeachment
proceedings not just against biden but
also justin justin trudeau
we can do that because canada
technically we have jurisdiction over
canada
as he was just bungling lgbtq it was a
delight you could tell how embarrassed
he was getting and he was red-faced not
black faith
which is rare for him
what's the combination if he's red-faced
and blackface i don't know i think just
blackface i think
that's my understanding i'm still
confused why you're the only person
who's allowed to compliment dagan's
appearance you're the only person here
with a wife yes
i'm just traveling out there she's right
you're you're married dave is married
we're all all of us are married we're
all married just
you're the only one to a wife
that's all i'm saying yeah yeah look on
on the hunter biden justin trudeau would
be freaking out about it what did we
call them which letter are they
[Laughter]
can i talk about hunter body for just a
second the story reminded me again to go
down the rabbit hole of how deeply
creepy the suppression of that whole
enterprise was i mean the new york post
not only got ignored and you went
through all of it in the monologue and
how they were delegitimized the new york
post was not allowed to tweet anything
for weeks that is bonkers and i think
one of the most important things about
this revelation from politico is it's
not like these emails were about hunter
biden's
colorful personal life they were about
his foreign business dealings about
which his father said he had never heard
anything never spoke to his son
and that appears to be very much
contradicted that's not about the
president's or then candidate's family
that's about the candidate now president
and i wonder if we can maybe revisit all
of it now yeah are we allowed to talk
about it now i think so and
also part of that is the the fact that
the media in big tech were involved
that's worthy of an investigation in
itself like shouldn't we ask like how
did the big tech get involved in this
like what what were those phone calls
like right and it's so clear-cut too i
mean i'm not a cyber security expert but
are you a homosexual no okay well then
that's okay
i'm a gay man on the inside
yeah that's a joke i'm just trying to
suppress
that's gone it's not the only thing
[Laughter]
nicely done
[Laughter]
it's about time someone said it
[Music]
but i would just think that if there's a
laptop that has tons of pictures of the
same guy smoking crack that it's
probably that guy's laptop but if it's
not wouldn't that mean that he had a
traveling crack bender photographer yes
that would also be an interesting story
exactly like if it wasn't his laptop and
you really believed that you would have
chased that story because that's even
crazier but they knew it was his laptop
the whole time which is why they said
that it wasn't um also did you hear jen
sake's explanation for why he didn't
answer any questions he said she said it
was boris johnson's fault because they
did not warn the white house that they
would be asking questions
which is probably because answering
questions is a pretty normal thing to do
for the leader of a free country they
threw boris johnson johnson under the
lorry
i know it's amazing isn't it this comes
from right out of here that was
incredible hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else